Simplifica "3a" multiplicado por "a" a la quinta, multiplicado por "a" cuadrada.
La propiedad de los exponentes que podemos usar aquí, cuando tenemos una misma base, en este caso "a"
es que si tenemos "a" elevado a la potencia "x"
por "a" elevado a la potencia "y",
esto es igual a "a" elevado a la potencia "x" más "y".
Y en breve veremos por que esto funciona así,
pero por lo pronto vamos a aplicarlo aquí.
Si tenemos "a" elevado a la potencia 5
por "a" elevado al cuadrado,
aplicando la propiedad,
esto es igual a "a" elevado a la potencia 5 más 2,
eso es a  lo que se reducen estos amigos,
y por supuesto aún tenemos...
aún tenemos "3a" por delante.
Aquí voy a hacer un paréntesis
y quiero mostrarte porque esto funciona.
Pensemos en lo que significa "a" elevado a la quinta
por "a" al cuadrado,
"a" a la quinta...
"a" a la quinta
literalmente significa,
"a" por "a", por "a"  por "a", por "a" cinco veces,
mientras que "a" cuadrada significa
"a" por "a"
y estamos multiplicando éstos entre sí,
estamos multiplicando estas 5 "a" por estas 2 "a".
Entonces, ¿qué hemos hecho?
Hemos multiplicado "a" por sí misma 5 veces,
y posteriormente otras 2 veces,
primero 5 veces y luego 2 veces,
pongamos esto claramente aquí.
Ésta de aquí es "a" a la quinta,
mientras ésta de aquí es "a" al cuadrado.
Al multiplicar a ambas ¿qué tenemos?
que estamos multiplicando "a" por sí misma,
un total de 5 más 2 que es 7  veces,
"a" a la séptima potencia,
"a" elevada a la potencia 5 más 2,
así que esto se simplifica como "3a" por "a" elevado a la séptima,  "a" a la séptima potencia.
Y ahora te podrías preguntar
¿Cómo aplicamos la propiedad aquí?
Bueno recordemos que "a"...
"a" simplemente es lo mismo que
"a" elevada a la potencia 1,
entonces aquí tenemos que es 3 por "a"
elevada a la potencia 1,
por "a" a la séptima,
y aquí aplicamos la regla nuevamente tenemos la misma base "a", "a" a la 1 por "a" la séptima,
nos da simplemente "a" a la octava,
aquí aplicamos la asociatividad de la multiplicación,
para hacer primero el producto de las "a",
para posteriormente multiplicar por 3.
Entonces "a" a la 1 por "a" la séptima,
es igual a "a" a la octava,
y esto multiplicado por 3,
"3a" a la octava.
Así es que 3 por "a", por "a" a  la quinta
por "a" al cuadrado,
se simplifica como
3 por "a" elevada a la octava potencia.